you look amazing I know I know you're
first we take your second tweeter
my first emperors I mean I know about
online I saw it all the time I saw
Salina an amazing performance and I just
I was like I wouldn't be a part of this
what is this why do you love this I mean
obviously there's like 16,000 kids here
we're inspiring that it's so many people
here today and it's such like a big
carpet oh my god I'm freaking out um and
it's for such a good cause and it makes
me so proud and humble coming to these
events you're like I want to do anything
I can to help I want to use my platform
to spread the word about we day I want
everyone to know what that is because I
still have friends that were like what's
we date I'm like what I mean like look
it up so I want to spread the word and I
want to help others and if we're on this
earth it's not helping someone what are
you doing you know I do feel like you
have this glow about you you're almost
six months into newlywed life yeah I got
the ring we're here oh yeah later bling
would have been the best part of these
past few months for you oh man it's so
good I highly recommend it to all my
friends
who are ready for that change in their
life because it is so awesome it's so
amazing he he got me a puppy another one
I have four dogs now when did he get you
a puppy like a week ago or something and
it's like the cutest little chihuahua
who have bad reps but like they're the
sweetest and and he's right now he's
babysitting our dog in my green room
right now would you name the dog willow
I don't ask you is it weird a little bit
that after you got married everyone
would like are you having babies yeah
and it gives in your head a lot like on
the honeymoon I was like am I supposed
to have a baby right now Mike and it
definitely it definitely shakes you I
guess because I'm not a lot of people
are like doing interviews with you like
when's baby number two and I'm like we
didn't get one yet yeah it's all about
the perfect timing so are you thinking
you're thinking about it though Oh every
single day on my life
yeah even before we were married I would
cry by while walking by diapers they
should be getting names yeah when are we
finally gonna get this album that I've
been waiting I feel like an eternity for
I got approved two days ago for my next
single so that thing that means things
are moving and we got dates finally but
it's a very funky song I think you're
gonna love it it's about what does it
call me I think it's called funk right
now we're working on the title button I
just dropped that
thank you so much good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]